each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we have two presenters competing for
planetary defense Steven Johnson that
can be together they're from University
oh so yeah I just want to acknowledge
this is El fizzy a team effort so I'm kg
together and I'm co-director of the
microsoft institute for high performers
competing at Sam so I have until with
Simon Cox Steven Johnson is our
postdoctoral researcher he's done all
the hard work and then Huw Lewis engrams
Trinidad two of our astronautics faculty
members who the sort of scientists on
that on this project so apologies the
resolution the laptops being a bit funny
so it's a little bit crunchy but
hopefully you can read it so so excited
we're from Microsoft Institute for hpc
as launched in 2005 by Bill Gates at
supercomputing and basically we're an
engineering department and we're looking
to see where we can use Microsoft tools
to try and help with engineering
processes so for the talk I a very brief
intro and cloud computing and why we're
using it in this application talk about
space situational awareness which is the
Neo asteroid impact scenario and
actually our demo which is on space
debris environment and then Steven here
is going to run alive as your demo and
which should be fun and then we'll just
conclude at the ends so cloud computing
so obviously and everybody has been
talking about cloud computing when we
come up problems and a scientist or
engineer comes us we don't say yeah use
cloud we don't say yeah use HPC we try
and understand the problem and we're
trying to use the most appropriate cost
effective resource that we we can so
looking at the cloud these are some of
the characteristics with the cloud one
of the features is its a pay-per-use
system what that means also is it
scalable so as we shouldn't previous
talk if you go your workflow the
workflow will scale
the computation depending whether you
need in the previous talk one machine 50
machines five thousand machines fifty
thousand machines you can scale out
scale back what that means is you get
burst capability so and that's what this
application requires so the fact that I
may only need a few computers today the
next week i might need 10,000 computers
for an hour and that burst capabilities
is what's important and if you have your
own facility and we're lucky enough to
have a brand new facility coming a lot
online in Southampton and you have
significant capital costs so we have a
new 8,000 processor machine at
Southampton it costs about five million
dollars you worry about utilization and
if you're not utilizing your machine the
people who've given you the money start
asking questions so cloud is quite nice
because it allows you to scale and you
have more of a subscription model and
that's what is quite nice we hope we
have reliability sustainability and also
the ability to access from anywhere so
at the moment these are the three main
cloud computing offerings amazon i guess
were first of the game google or next
and microsoft bringing up the rear here
with as your so this is the sort of span
so amazon basically gives you a box in
the cloud gives you a vm and you have to
do everything okay so you have to upload
your image build your image run it
manage it you have a fixed IP for a
machine although they're fixing that now
so you can have flexible ip's Google's
at the other end Google gives you a
Python runtime or a java runtime facet
don't think you can get a file system
microsoft somewhere in the middle where
you get an operating system so you get
things like a file system an analogy to
that that i like to use is if you're
going for some web hosting you can rent
a dedicated box they give you a box load
whatever you want on that box costs a
fair bit money you can go to the other
end when you say actually I just want to
run a website so i want to pay five
bucks a month and i want to run a CMS
like drupal joomla i just want to put
some webpages on there in the middle you
might go to somebody like Rackspace and
say well actually want a server and i
want windows server on that and they
give me a sequel on there and some
is but I'm going to load some apps on
there too so it's somewhere in the
middle and obviously depending what your
business is and what you're trying to do
you want to use the most appropriate
solution so that's my three minute guide
cloud computing space situational
awareness is what this application is
about space situational awareness is
really about you know the area of space
around the earth it's very important for
operating space vehicles those
satellites launch vehicles and that sort
of thing what's happening is that every
time we launch a vehicle say a rocket
stage separates you end up with a dead
rocket stage you end up with all the
bits like bolts and things that come off
the rocket stage and a lot of those
things stay in orbit and so we get this
debris cloud basically it's often called
space junk and what can happen is things
can run into other things in the case of
cosmos and iridium two satellites can
hit each other and that's obviously very
bad and it also creates more debris so
the subsequent of that is that for
instance on the space shuttle on the
recent Hubble mission there's a one in
eighty-nine percent chance for a
national actually being killed and r1
into 2nite chance of the Space Shuttle
being hit the Space Shuttle has had to
replace 92 windows because of space
debris that's usually due to something
like a paint Fleck the size of my
fingernail hitting at 17,000 miles an
hour it's a lot of kinetic energy and so
debris is a big big big problem however
it's not nearly as big a problem as an
asteroid hitting the earth because it
could be the end of us all we will enter
the Carnegie Museum and we saw the
dinosaurs there that could be us okay so
that is another issue space situational
awareness also covers space weather so
things like solar activity that can
knock out satellites and things so it's
a concert in order to manage this okay
we need to observe so we need to look
and see what's out in space we need to
observe the satellites look at Neos find
out where they are that generates a lot
of data from that data we might want to
do some modeling and prediction and from
that prediction we might want to take
some action so in the state in the case
of space debris for instance
we may spot a piece of debris and we may
need to move the International Space
Station out of the way and they do that
on a regular basis it's an international
problem because space is you know an
international issue for everybody and
actually this work at Southampton we
help to inform the United Nations
Committee on peaceful use of space and
actually the space debris modeling that
you'll see is used to help form un
policy on space debris and space debris
mitigation and also licensing of
satellites see when you actually want to
launch a satellite we have to do some
analysis to make sure you're putting it
into an orbital slot that doesn't
interfere with other satellites of the
work you'll sing here I've actually
involved in that so planetary defense is
important so the space situational
awareness issue is quite big so and
people are concerned with this so the
u.s. is spending nine billion dollars
over the next five years on this space
situational awareness the Europe has
been during several billion euros on
space situational awareness so this is a
tricky one to asteroid so there are
thousands of asteroids spinning around
the solar system if an asteroid bigger
than a kilometer across hits the earth
we're all dead basically it's what we
call a civilization killer and the odds
that happen happening hopefully are
quite small but if it did happen it's
going to be bad but like I said the odds
of that happening are quite small there
is a single the Torino scale on the
right which is a scale of severity the
civilization killers are basically eight
nine or ten in its combination of
probability of hitting and also the size
of the impact what's of a greater
concern are the smaller asteroids
because these things are quite hard to
spot so the US government has tasked
NASA with spot with tracking every
kilometer sized asteroids actually in
Congress they passed a bill and they
ring-fence some money so that NASA had
to do that and they're pretty much on
the way there so that's the big stuff
the small stuff however is quite
dangerous so in 1908 an asteroid didn't
actually impact it was an air burst over
Siberia
and that had a power of about fifteen
megatons okay and it flattened an area
the size of London okay these things
have a higher probability of hitting the
earth about one in ten chance of that
happening in us in this century okay so
these are the things that we're really
worrying about now because when these
things come past sometimes we don't see
them till they've already gone past the
earth so that means that one day maybe
one might not get past the earth and
actually hit the earth so these are the
ones that were actually very worried
about there is one particular asteroid
called Apophis which is suitably named
which is about 270 meters across in 2029
it will pass within our ring of
geostationary satellites okay that's
quite scary we are seeing in daylight
okay and hopefully if it's not getting
any bigger that's good if that were to
impact in it is jus there was a scare in
2004 when we were observing this and the
prot the odds of it impacting went up to
1 in 37 that went to number four on the
scale there on the right subsequently as
the observation started coming in than
the calculations were refined that
probability reduced which was good and
at the moment in fact about 10 days ago
they announced a revised estimate which
means it's one in 25,000 that's based on
observations from telescopes and there's
an opportunity in 2013 when it does a
close approach that we can put something
on the asteroid so we can know exactly
where it is because if it were to impact
this is when it would impact Britney
diaries and it would impact with
equivalent of 818 megatons that's four
times the power of the Krakatau volcano
which had a very significant effect on
global climate we essentially had a
nuclear winter so this is a problem and
so we are involved in trying to do some
modeling around this this is something I
haven't quite recently something hit
Jupiter and there's the scar that scar
is the size of the earth okay so there
are Astra and we didn't see this one
coming we're not really
but you know it happened and took
everyone by surprise so it's it's a
little bit scary what we're going to
talk about today actually is the space
debris aspect so this is one of our
models and it's the model that we've
deployed in Azure which show which
allows us to track satellites and these
this is a modeling we did if the Iridium
Cosmo satellite collision and you can
see how you know we've got the orbits
and then we see what happens in middle
when they collide and then subsequently
what happened so this is actually what
we're going to do a demo about today and
like I said there are a lot of fragments
out there and this is becoming an
increasing problem about 10,000 objects
in orbit that are quite big at about
300,000 objects that are about size the
fingernails sort of thing that hits
space shuttle and we want to be able to
track those and model those in order to
track them we have telescopes so there
are some proposed new European
telescopes your penis you're spending
about a billion on these new telescopes
because this affects our space
infrastructure communications
observation and military and so this is
the sort of global network of sensors
and what we need to do is if we want to
try and tackle these this debris issue
we need to track all these objects and
we need to share the information about
those objects because if you're a
Russian satellite operator and an
American satellites going to hit you you
kind of need to know you might want to
talk to each other so the problem is
that people don't always like to reveal
their sensors if you're the US military
and you have a very good sensor you
might not want somebody else to know
that that sensor exists ok so the
anonymity of where some data comes from
is quite important for a lot of users
and supplies of information so Richard
Tremayne Smith is one of the people who
runs this activity at the British
National Space Center recent retired
said these few things and one of the
things he says was well why don't we put
a software application between the
really sensitive data and the sensor
data and the end users and so we thought
hey that's a good idea so we've come up
with this idea which is a service bus
for space sexual relational awareness
and which in our case it's in Azure
and that is allow able to consume
information ground observation space
observations and in the cloud we can or
we can distribute that information but
we can sanitize it okay we can have a
scale of fidelity depending on access
control and then we can actually have
simulation tools in the cloud which is
what we're going to show now and then
the results from those can be used by
decision-makers and satellite operators
and in the case of the neo impacts
decision-makers emergency authorities in
order to plan for that so this idea of a
global computing platform to help
everybody because it's an international
problem everybody has a stake in this is
what we're going to show off and I shall
hand over to Steve he's going to do the
demo Steve
okay right thanks lark ng so what I'm
going to show you today is and as your
demo that we've got and just to give you
a brief overview of the features of
azure that we're using and it was
briefly mentioned earlier on today there
are two types of worker roles well as a
web role and work a role in as Europe
the the way brawl has access to is but
essentially they're just units of
processing so we're using both web and
worker roles we're using me as your
tables and as your tables slightly
different it's not like a sequel table
you can't you can't join them it's not
transactional to some extent and but the
point is that it's super scalable to you
you should be able to scale up too many
millions and millions of rows to index a
row in a table it's indexed by a
partition key and then a rocky and we're
storing data the binary data in blobs
this is your blobs and also I'm taking
advantage of the local storage which is
not persistent but every worker has a
disc that you can write some scratch
space to basically and one of the key
features of cloud computing is that you
want to be able to make it to scale very
well and so you need to have some way of
allocating work to these worker roles to
do this we're using data driven queues
and and so every worker comes along and
picks off the next piece of work from
the queue we're also using relational
databases so this is sequel Azure which
was released about three weeks ago and
I've actually ported this to the sequel
as your production hardware now which
was released two days ago so it's quite
exciting that that's all up and running
now and I'm going to show you a little
front end that we've put together and
using Virtual Earth and expat and WPF
and I'll talk about that in a minute so
how does it all work now imagine if you
were like a satellite owner what you
basically get a text message that says
my satellite is going to collide with
something how do you get this
information well space track actually
publish a list of about ten thousand
objects that's debris and satellites
they publish it twice a day
there are other sources or amateur
astronomers which published tles so the
first stages I've got an importer or a
worker process that goes long and you
can harvest tles tle is a two line
element they're actually three lines in
it which is good because the acronym
still works and the tle is basically the
position as an orbit of that it's the
orbit that the piece of that the object
is taking at that current point in time
and I tle is a standard format is used
by many applications so the first stage
is to import these tles and to store
them as as your blobs not doing any
processing on them there's just this
worker that goes along and harvests them
and the point I'd like to make out here
is that this middle box is each one of
these it's going to appear as we go
along is a worker roll and you can scale
these up and down depending on your
workload so once you've got your tle
next stage is obviously to validate it
there's a little checksum in there and
there's some other validation you can do
just to make sure that you've actually
got the correct information and all the
tea Ellie's are then turned into tell
the objects and throw it into a queue
this is where the real work starts so
you can take these you can take your tle
object off of the queue and the first
thing you need to do is to see well do I
have it already because you might have
got it from another source so I have a
tle table at the bottom there and that
stores all of my tea Ellie's ever and I
do a quick look up in there to see if
the t really exists if it does I ignore
it because I've done I've processed it
already if it doesn't exist I add it to
the table and then I add a notification
to an update queue to let other workers
know that hey look I've updated this
this tle or I've got a new tle so I tle
basically is the position of this object
now but you want to know that your
satellites going to collide maybe in a
few hours time or in a few days time so
you need to propagate this object and
for that we're using a propagator
I've got two different propagators for
this as SGB for which is a fairly basic
one and we're also using a propagator
that was developed in-house at
Southampton the propagator it was
developed in house in Southampton is
about 25,000 lines of sea with another
20 odd thousand lines of look up tables
so it's quite substantial and and this
is actually running up in the cloud now
today and to do that we're using P
invoke if anyone was interested in the
technology there so um so basically
calculate where where is your object
going to be in the future and I have
another big table here basically stores
future positions of objects so now you
have you have a you have a list of all
the TL ease all the objects that you
know about you know where all these
objects are going to be in the future so
the next thing to do is to take a look
at this and see if any of these are
going to have a conjunction a collision
so there's another worker process that
will come along and check for any
conjunctions and we're writing them to
sequel as your as sequel as your is the
relational database and all of this
information here is accessible well
either through thee as your API or and
it's all rest of all as well so
regardless of how regardless of what
you're wanting to do with it afterwards
all of this information is it is
accessible in a standard format it's
used in industry today so gotta tle
table on my propagation table and I've
got a list of conjunctions now so the
next thing is basically we can make that
public people can download that and do
their own analysis on it to demonstrate
how it works I've got a client that I've
written and basically it will help
visualize something now bear in mind i
did say these tles are published twice a
day and so today it was published at
about six o'clock this morning and
hopefully that's all that processing
there has been done this morning and
we're going to look at the most likely
conjunctions collisions that are going
to happen today now
so let me just switch or we have to
excuse the resolution I'm afraid so when
you when you look at an object you're
not really looking just at the object
it's more like a probability zone so
it's like an ellipse if those two
ellipses cross each other then that
classed as a conjunction chances are
they probably won't hit but you don't
really know where the object is inside
that and inside that ellipse feet yep
and that's where the quality of data is
important because you might find oh
there's a possible conjunction you might
then go back to the satellite operators
and say can you give us more detailed
information about where your satellites
going to be in order for us to refine
that uncertainty that's the stable yeah
because the tle doesn't actually give
you a very accurate position so this was
space track that i mentioned that are
publishing the the catalog and here just
to prove that it is all running and this
is big i am afraid and this is my worker
processes here this is the azure portal
and now here's for the show so i wanted
to use Virtual Earth to display these
orbits and you can use Virtual Earth API
but it's JavaScript and by time you
start loading up with many thousands and
thousands of points it's going to slow
down however you can host Virtual Earth
yourself now because you can host it
yourself you can also host it inside a
WPF application WPF application is
windows presentation foundation which is
the next version of windows forms
effectively they are with me so the
point is now that I've got it into our
WPF application you can stream the
application through the browser so now I
can stream virtual air through the
browser and here's how it's going to
work it's called an expat so when I
click on this and I'm doing this on
whilst the laptops on battery through
the wireless here and it's in the zero
damn
so here goes it's going to down it's
downloading the application from a zero
and it's going to run it locally in a
sandbox and I think this is a key point
here that what's happening is this is
real software plus services you have a
thick client that's capable of using
activate that's capable of using the
local hardware but it is odd mented by
services are up in the cloud and I think
this sort of hybrid technology is where
it's going to go you're never going to
say look move everything to the cloud
move everything locally and to prove
that it's get there go to prove that
it's actually running on this machine
here if you look at the hardware
acceleration on it you'll see that it's
very smooth so here's the first example
and where is the international space and
space station now well it's on that line
there and this is an orbit that's been
pulled off of my tle propagation so one
of these lines that's where it starts
now and the propagation takes it for
about 12 hours into the future yes yes
it is configurable and just to show that
it's all as you would expect you can get
lost you can zoom in and everything so
all the standard Virtual Earth features
are available and that will startle up
the resolution in a minute there we go
so let me turn on some stars helps you
there as a have a reference point and I
think the first the most likely
conjunction today hasn't come through
yet but I'm very sure the second one has
and there it is so we'll turn off the
yellow one was the ISS will turn that
off just now
there we go so the red and the white
lines are two different satellites and
you can see you can see that if I hold
it up to the edge you can see that there
is the two paths to cross each other get
Oaks I think all the rest look roughly
the same so here's another one so the
key point is and I know this is a very
simple client and there's something I've
done but the fact that all the data is
available in a standard format means
that you can use it in other pieces of
software such as a GIS SDK which is the
sort of the industry standard software
for doing conjunction and satellite
tracking one last thing I wanted to show
and that is the ability to basically
look at your what's called the cloud
drive as an example application that
basically lets you look at your blob
storage that's up in the cloud and also
if I change to my queue drive this will
give you a list of all my cues that were
used to support the application and
giving you the message count in them
just to just give you a feel that you
know it is all actually up and running
and i think that's it i'm going to hand
back to Kenji's going to a quick lasts
summary
so that was the I'm going to get it back
to PowerPoint for me thanks no not at
all that the conjunction analysis is at
a particular time do their lap what time
do they relax oh no we can't see that in
there yet no that's just we haven't put
that into the initialized you don't
solve application which the astronomers
already are using such as eg is SDK yes
an excellent piece of software they
spent millions Reyes you can't compete
with that the idea was just to show
short of cool technology and just
develop a very simple client to help you
visualize what's actually going on
underneath so that might be a simple
client you do and then you phone up your
operator and say so if you're on the
road and you get text and says your
satellites going to collide you think oh
go into an internet cafe fire the web
app go and you can phone up your
operator he fires up the full software
and then over the cloud can pull it down
on their machine with the full software
to then talk to you over the phone and
you can say okay you need to do a
maneuver in three hours they do these
spiral maneuvers to move the satellite
so it's it's you know it's that sort of
ability so so what we're doing now is
we're extending this platform so we've
got this kind of idea of the storage and
the workers and all of these tools and
so what we're now doing is extending
that for the neo problem and so what we
need to do where we've got the tles want
to do some neo detection talking to Alex
about the pan-starrs projects which are
very exciting digital telescope and
hopefully we can work with Alex to see
if we can pull in the pan-starrs data
into our as your workflow here then we
want to do trajectory modeling so you
need to again this is what was happening
on the prophus people were keeping it
updating their trajectory modeling
what's interesting there is actually
looking at impact modeling we have a
global impact model that shows that if
the asteroid hits off the west coast of
the u.s. there are going to be this many
casualties because we're gonna get a
tsunami and earthquake of blast wave and
so doing all of that modeling but as you
refine the trajectory your impact point
is going to change you then need to
re-run your impact modeling code so this
is what we're putting in and then
there's deflection planning so at the
bottom right you can see a gravity
tractor spaceship that's being designed
by Astrium so if an asteroid is coming
and it's going to hit you might want to
move it out the way lots of people go
why are we just nuke it two things if
your new kit you change the trajectory
it may be that it was going to land in
the middle of Pacific and it's now going
to land in the middle of the east coast
of the USA because you've accidentally
deflected it wrong and the other thing
is if you blow up an asteroid you get a
shotgun effects a rather than getting
one big asteroid you might get a hundred
fifty meter asteroids so you may just
blow up or more of a part of the
continent and the last thing is decision
support so this is where we actually
want to help the decision makers whether
their governments okay so one of the
films they did on TV just trying to
convince the u.s. that the US should
take the hit because there'd be fewer
casualties if it landed in the Arizona
desert than if it landed in Europe so
decision-making can be at that level
okay and so we want a tool that's up so
the US Air Force ran an exercise in
December last year where they had the US
Air Force Department of Homeland
Security or the emergency serve services
local government federal government and
they try to do this and they couldn't
pull all the information together look
at it and make decisions and that was in
December so it's a big it's a big big
problem actually because like I said
little or no warning or one of these
things is going to hit so we're not
quite ready yet and we're trying to get
there so just to wrap up we look to
cloud computing it's early days this is
the first time we've really written
anything for the cloud but we've decided
as always to do quite an end-to-end
application to solve a real problem for
this particular application we think
it's a pretty good fit in terms of you
know we've looked at climate change in
the oceans you know what's the potential
benefit to humanity for this where we
could to save the planet potentially
that's a good one and we think it's a
new paradigm for programming really and
so we're pretty excited with this and
it's been a really good experience so if
you want to talk to us about it then
please do so our email addresses are
there so thank you very much thanks
so when are you gonna finish you have a
22 South what you now see that's 29 yeah
yeah it's going to take us that long to
get the funding well I don't have that
many instances on a little bit of stock
i'm using eight okay that but it's
actually embarrassing with parallel task
because all you're doing is propagating
where is my object going to be in the
future you can do that for all 10,000 in
parallel it's then the conjunction so we
like more azul compute time please to
demonstrate the burst capability but
we're limited to the beta basically
which was a workers but we would like
more work innate and it's a grey the
update twice a day how long did you from
the update so you have the data so not
too long about 3-4 hours but does not
running on many know so night notes
severity scale so we wait yeah you don't
want to just look at 12 hours you want
to be looking a week in advance so for
example I the eridian one they have to
upload their maneuvers have my maneuvers
14 hours in advance so that's a problem
if you're looking for a week would be
very nice you can't go much more than a
week so we'd like to show the
scalability of the application be nice
to to do that do that experiment we I
know that the cord goes long
a week because who uses it for a very
long time like one or two years but the
problem is the data you're putting in
tlas bar area
how variable is the workload I haven't
understood why the cloud is better than
just a dedicated server doing this so
there's this two scenarios twice a day
I'm obviously hitting load by high load
for two to four hours and the other
thing is imagine when there is a
collision the last collision there any
one produced next 2,000 objects I'm only
tracking 10,000 already but that could
have been a lot worse because all of
those satellites in the constellation
are in the same orbit are the same
altitude anyway so the chances are you
can get a snowball effect where we take
out all the satellites in the area so
potentially you're looking at hundreds
of thousands of pieces of data to be no
objects to track the other thing is that
those 10,000 obvious that we're
currently tracking there's actually
about 300,000 that we would like to
track so in the future that's me to
scale up since this burst capability
cell lysates when those tears are
published you want to be able to do the
computation quickly and then if you've
got a conjunction you're worried about
you then want to just do the computation
and if your satellite is worth three or
four hundred million dollars you're
willing to pay for that extra bit of
compute whereas what you don't want is a
warehouse of 5,000 sheet and sitting
there doing nothing for 364 days except
for that so that's why this for that
it's really important for the neo
scenario so for the neo so in the event
of a national emergency the US
government can commandeer airliners they
did it for the Iraq war so here yes
government could commandeer a cloud data
center and say right well actually we
kind of want to calculate this where
this Neos going to hit and then suddenly
you've got a fixed amount of time when
this thing's coming to the earth and
you're wanting to do is especially for
the decision support and the impact and
so they're having that so actually for
these scenarios which are kind of what
if it might not happen but when it does
happen we really need to respond quickly
so these emergency scenarios this is
quite an interesting infrastructure so
you can imagine for emergency services
again for disaster response or something
like Hurricane Katrina that type of
thing where you needed to model
something very quickly this is quite
quite useful so potentially for weather
modeling it could be quite interesting
to be able to do that so again it's yeah
we would that's why we chose to use this
realize that I've got an A Thousand
processing machine but again it's a
utilization see so it's not necessarily
good for any application but for this
application it's the burst
so would some day after you die
nope so basically every worker process
if it dies the items will reappear back
on the queue again and so will are
getting process with the next worker
that comes out of the line so I know
that so whether I'm I do have an event
this is it something is happening here
because I've actually have rewritten
accused me make them because I know
whether or just be checked out or
project where they've gone so I can tell
is if something has been updated but the
user doesn't get notified currently now
ok so the same job company can one buy
arms from
what do you have the huge data no no I
mean the catalog probably only a few
megabytes I can expand there's gigabytes
in the other thing here actually we're
keeping the day or in the cloud so we're
not pulling the data back to the client
we're doing all the processing in the
cloud yes we don't have to pull that
gigabyte beta down well thank you